what else has happened we've got some
real life going on britney's free yeah
that was kind of
um
i was like
jealous
that she's free
i mean that's just like a level of fame
that you could only
aspire to have which like you win a
court case and people are like stacked
up outside a courthouse for you yeah
like not even rappers get that kind of
treatment big rappers you know they go
do time and they come out it's just
their friends waiting there their fans
don't even really show up yeah he's like
the one guy trying to get the autograph
yeah it's so rude you know [ __ ] i just
did three years and you want me to do an
autograph yeah [ __ ] you yeah britney
wasn't even at the courthouse and
they're doing a [ __ ] full-on tailgate
that is like just a crazy level of fame
to achieve you know but good for her
how would you kill her dad
[Laughter]
xlax in the pasta
like force fed or like is this a slow
burn
no i would just put
put laxatives in this pasta i mean he's
old as [ __ ] he could definitely die like
an organ trail death
[Music]
organ trail yeah
what's that it's like a double meaning
but like the game the oregon trail oh
okay and then like you could dive like
dysentery or whatever
[Music]
uh
it's a game
it's life it's a [ __ ] trail in real
life i mean
yeah but i'm a zoomer so
i'm 14. so i think the organization i'm
13. so yeah i just think that oregon
trail is just a game he you could
definitely get him that way he he he he
he he he
he
just take away all the water in his
house and feed him x-lax monster
yeah just shut all his organs out that's
[ __ ] up
i don't think any organs would come out
i think he'd just [ __ ] and then die
eventually yeah from he'd be like
spongebob you know water
[Music]
i think if i could i would just give him
really bad tinnitus like the ear ringing
thing yeah titniss tennis yeah give him
tittiness yeah a little bit of tedious
wait speaking of which did you see that
matthew mcconaughey clip no oh you're
gonna love this oh my god can we play
that serve my boy
that bad that i was just gonna if
the audio just wasn't gonna work i was
gonna say we could just make up what
he's saying coming at you this time as a
pickle
expert to talk about pickles which i
love so dearly we have to go back to
their origin story
the cucumber
now look at this cucumber big plump firm
gold
i promise every mom right now just went
yeah
yes yes gladly this far in you know fern
gay men got hopes too yeah that's like
ah is this gonna be good and then
he should just [ __ ] just deep down
you take a bite
it's all
hat no cattle it's all packaging no
product it has no identity it is
tasteless
all it does is take up room in our
proverbial salads
[Applause]
dude this is a open mic when it gets
older this is a first time open mic it's
like a fine wine does it get better and
become
a pickle
not as firm as it once was got a few
more bumps on it it even shrunk
let's see what it tastes like
um
now we got the product
behind the packaging that's right now
we've got identity that's right
inside every big dick
there's a future shriveled small dick
that tastes better that's the whole
purpose of this message it's not about
the size
it's about the flavor yeah
see ladies that's what you've been
missing is with small penises is
you don't just suck them you got to bite
into them yeah that's where the real
flavor is yeah yeah my dick might be
small but it tastes really sour yeah
what the [ __ ]
you ever had pickled penis and that
the smaller and more shriveled it is
pickled penis is an old man's penis
got a couple bumps on it
sugar daddy dick is just referred to his
pickled penis oh it was so small and so
sour just absolutely sour delectable
salty
so salty
yeah that's what that is man
if you bite into a small penis it'll
give you flavor like you've never had
before you think his wife popped in and
was like what the [ __ ] are you doing he
has a wife yeah
i for sure thought this dude had like a
harem
i thought he's one of the only guys left
doing polyamory like the old-school way
yeah sorry his five wives yeah i thought
he had like 30 wives
he owns like a compound in new mexico
somewhere but he owns this in austin
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah a small suburban
town yeah that's all his wives that live
in the houses yeah they're all in unison
all 30 of them in the
room
what are living
making a pickle video
come in here and have sex with us all 30
of us i'm tired of having sex
all packaged no product is what sex is
taking up space
it's just the stupidest [ __ ] like
what in his mind thought that this was
good content
you know what i'm saying i mean like a
good subject anything
he bro he's like one of the he's like a
corpse husband it no matter he this dude
could tweet literally us a picture of
his nut skin
50 000 likes on twitter like he just got
engagement dude it's not fair
you're just jealous dude i am jealous
you wish you could do a pickle video and
get the same engagement as him yeah
i do
me too yeah you yeah see of course i
think anyone does i made a point about
like i made a video yesterday
you know it's cause some kid told me
like
a while back he's like oh farts aren't
funny i'm like dude
there are fart videos
on youtube yeah there are fart
compilation videos on youtube with more
views than like
the original dune probably yeah yeah you
know yeah like casablanca probably
doesn't have as many views and ticket
sales as like a far complicated
downloads as the fart app remember that
yeah yeah
farts aren't funny that's honestly
making me pissed
it's not even funny
i'm like angry at that kid
i mean how could anyone even yeah how
could how could you begin to articulate
such a thought
but yeah i'm just gonna forget about it
let it go let it go calm down calm down
it's your birthday what were we watching
oh yeah matthew
no it's good content though no this is
honestly kind of inspiring for me
you know because this guy's just sold
like
how many millions of copies of his
[ __ ] memoir book yeah that he wrote
yeah how many [ __ ] movies has he done
with incredible story lines and yet he
cannot make a minute long video
that's
like at all good
like that's pretty inspiring is it not
yeah we haven't even watched the last 15
seconds yet oh let's go now we've got
purpose because we're a pickle sour
sweet
dill
it commits
it's the pickle
and you do tickle
my fancy
i was wrong that video actually rolled
dill's not a flavor dude
do you hear him yeah sweet sour dill
dill is a [ __ ] plant
i don't know i don't need it's a herb
it's a herb
that's not a flavor yeah
isn't it you're [ __ ] how many copies
of a book a [ __ ] book you just sell
wait isn't it like sour pickle dill
pickle
yeah it is damn you just got dunked on
you got dunked on by matt just just
admit you're jealous dude i am jealous
what are the what are the comments i see
the comments oh my god squirt your
pickle juice on them and see why you got
to say stuff like that these
i'd love to taste your pickle jesus damn
meredith
shove your fat tiny pickle down my
[ __ ] whoa
i'll take your tasteless cucumber any
day oh
i swear this man could talk about air
and i would listen and he would give us
one of the best life analogies don't
give him any ideas i love all the random
accounts trying to get engagement like
that cinema file what is that
cinema spectacle all right all right all
right
just didn't even watch the video
comments that on every single video
you know they say
i was not expecting to learn about
pickles on my sunday evening yet i
wasn't disappointed crying okay
cool yeah as [ __ ] yeah get that out mary
this was the best thing i've ever
watched
what the [ __ ] kind of life do you lead
a horny one
[Laughter]
like
you are definitely like no one is
watching
matthew mcconaughey to me i think is
just you know
that's ass pics for
for at least straight women you know
that's the equivalent of an aspect the
internet's so funny because no matter
like unless you're an egregiously like
offensive creator like the comments are
this for everyone yeah such a false
positive
it really is
it really is it's like you're in your
own
world where people were like dude
literally scorsese if he saw this
would literally end his own life and
probably sign over his entire net worth
and company to you
because
he would realize he has no idea what
he's doing it's [ __ ] ryan's toys like
you